for our next award I'm going to ask
Ronald Regan to leave the radio booth
long enough to make the presentation
ladies and gentlemen this award goes to
a fellow guild member and Hollywood's
best citizen president of the motion
picture Relief Fund and for four very
important progressive years president of
this Academy distinguished radio
personality and an actor of Academy
Award stature before many of tonight's
contestants were born this Oscar to Jean
Herschel
you
ladies and gentlemen on this coming
Sunday it's the 26th of March it's
exactly 44 years ago since I made my
first picture in 1906 in Denmark it was
only a 300-foot feature that took us
about four hours to make it's a long
down jump from that 300-foot flash to
this magnificent affair tonight I'm very
very proud of having been privileged to
be a member of this industry for so many
years thank you
the next special award will be presented
by Donald O'Connor
thank you very much sorry Francis
couldn't be with me tonight but he's
home making out his speech for next year
this award is for the best performance
by a child actor or actress during the
year 1949 it goes to the little boy
whose performance in the window and so
dear to my heart and chanted moviegoers
and critics alike Bobby Driscoll
I don't really think I've been so
thrilled in my life but I want to thank
everybody that had to do with me getting
this award I want to thank God for
giving me such a wonderful mother
congratulations Bobby and Thank You
Donald